satellite de communication de navigation
ou d'observation des objets d'étude du
séminaire quel espace dans 20 ans
organisé à l'estaca de montigny le
bretonneux avec un message de thomas
pesquet depuis la station spatiale
internationale pour ouvrir les
discussions
nous allons envoyer ces quelques mots
d'encouragement ci a pas si longtemps du
moyenne semblent j'étais comme vous avec
mes rêves un peu fou et des projets et
je vous souhaite de tout coeur de
pouvoir réaliser des autres des
spécialistes de l'aéronautique et de
l'aérospatial vont pouvoir partager
leurs expériences avec les étudiants des
quatre écoles d'ingénieurs du groupe isa
et j'en sais pas grand chose sur les
et les satellites militaires ou les
opérations militaires qui peut y avoir
eu
et donc du coup ça m'intéresse aussi
d'en apprendre de ce côté là j'espère
pouvoir découvrir un petit peu un sujet
que je connais pas que je connais pas
vraiment même si on étudie un petit peu
en cours différentes différentes
missions dans le système solaire
je veux dire que voilà je connais pas
les détails les particularités de ce
genre de mission ces moments d échanges
permettent aussi de créer des réseaux
entre les étudiants ici les étudiants
des quatre écoles donc de
salon-de-provence de poitiers de
toulouse et de saint quentin en yvelines
et puis aussi de laval ont la
possibilité de se rencontrer un pendant
une semaine de travailler ensemble
il ya une attente particulière sur eux
de ddd français c'est qu'ils soient le
coeur de l'innovation pour contribuer au
développement économique ou à la
recherche scientifique ces étudiants ont
une semaine pour imaginer l'univers
spatial de demain
[Musique]